شكرا للزميل نايف اعزائي المشاهدين اسعد
الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى هذه
التغطيه المستمره للتطورات الدراماتيكيه
في السودان بعد المنعرج الخطير الذي دخلته
البلاد منذ ثمانيه ايام فقد تحدث رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني والقائد العام
للجيش الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
للعربيه منذ قليل مؤكدا مشاطرته المجتمع
الدولي القلق اتجاه الرعايه الاجانب في
السودان واكد ان الوضع في تدهور مستمر
وحمل قوات الدعم السريع مسؤوليه التعدي
على البعثات الدبلوماسيه دون مراعاه
للقانون الدولي
وكشف البرهان عن ان كل مطارات البلاد تحت
سيطرات الجيش ما عدا مطري الخرطوم ونيالا
حتى الان
البرهان اتهم الدعم السريع بالانتشار في
الاحياء السكنيه واستخدام المدنيين كدروع
بشريه
قائد الجيش اكد انه سيدافع عن مقر القياده
العامه للجيش وانه لن يغادره الا على نعش
وعن موقع قائد قوات الدعم السريعه الجنرال
احمدتي قال البرهان انه حتى قوات الجنرال
ديجلو لا تعرف مكانه
انا موجود في هيئه قياده القوات المسلحه
ومضارحه ولن ابارحها هذه هي مهنتي وهذا
شرفي لن اخرج الا محمولا على نعش لكن انا
موجود واقوم بواجبي دستوري وادافع عن
الدوله السودانيه ولا ادافع عن شخص ولا
ادافع عن جهه
[موسيقى]
دافع عن بقاء مدافع عن السودانيين جميعا
انا موجود صحيح المنزل تم تسلل نصوص اظن
ذلك نصوص
من بعض المنزل
هو ليس داخل القياده بالمعنى انه تسلل
لبعض النصوص وعاصوا فيه فتاه
احد يعلم
اذا كذب صريح وهو يعلم تماما انني ليست
لدي اي علاقه بالنظام السابق ولا جميع
يعلم ذلك نحن قوات مسلحه
في السودان حتى
معظم هذه الاشاعه يعلم المصداقيه ويعلم
انه انها كلمه حق اريد بها باطل او كلمه
باطل فيها
لمزيد من المتابعه ينضم الي من الخرطوم
الان عبد الرحمن خليل وهو الناطق الرسمي
باسم الخارجيه السودانيه سعاده السفير
اهلا وسهلا بك الى هذه التغطيه من العربيه
انا ادرك حساسيه الوضع حساسيه المواقف
الان وانك لا تريد الدخول في اي نقاش
عسكري او امني حول مجريات الامور لذا
ساكتفي بسؤالك حول الاتصالات السياسيه
وعمليات الاجلاء لنبدا باخر الاتصالات
والمشاورات السياسيه لتثبيت وقف اطلاق
النار اين وصلت هذه الجود ساعات السفير
ولماذا لم تصمد اي هدنه حتى الساعه
السودان ومنطلق ومن طلق حرص حرصوا على على
على توفير
المناعه الملائم لاجلاع الرعايه
والمساعدات الانسانيه وتوفير الاحتياجات
الضروريه للمواطنين اعلن الهدنه لمده
ثلاثه ايام وسودان ملتزم بذلك التزاما
تاما غير ان
الدعم السريع الحركه المتمرده هي التي
بدات بالخروقات
وفي مناطق عده ولكن
القوات المسلحه تتصدى لذلك
وتكبرها على التراجع ولكن عموما
الالتزام بالهده مستمره ولا والقوات
المسلحه ملتزمه بذلك سعاد سفير هل يمكن
اجراء اي عمليه اجراء في حال لم يتثبت وقف
اطلاق النار وهنا السؤال كيف وضمن اي شرو
ط يمكن الوصول لوقف لاطلاق النار لتامين
هذه العمليه
السودان ملتزم بوخفي باطلاق النار او
الهدنه
عمليه الايداع وكذلك
الدعم الدعم السريع المتمرده ايضا
فيما اعلم اعلن اعلن ذلك ولكننا نخشى انها
تبدي بعض الخروقات ولكن على الارض يعني
الارض تشتعل يعني لا وجود لاي يعني تثبيت
لوقف اطلاق النار
نعم نعم نعم في بعض في بعض المناطق لكن
الحكومه السودانيه والقوات المسلحه تسعى
لتامين ممرات امنه
للدول التي ترغب في اجلال دبلوماسيه
ورعاياها وذلك بالتنسيق تنسيق الامني
المحكم
طيب سعاده السفير هنالك حديث عن بعثات
ولجان وساطه ستزور الخرطوم في محاوله
لايجاد حلول هنالك حديث عن وفد من الجامعه
العربيه قد ياتي من الايجاد من كينيا لو
تطلعنا في صوره هذه الاتصالات
كثير من الجهاد ابدت ابدت رغبتها
لاجراء الوساطه
لكن لكن في الوقت الحالي القوات المسلحه
يعني
معظم جهدها في التصدي للمحاول الانقلابيه
وللمتمردين
ولكنها ولكنها تكون يعني
منفتحه بعد بعد انجاز المهمه واستدباب
الاوضاع ان شاء الله هل هنالك اي وفد سواء
عربي او دولي سيصل في الايام المقبله الى
الخرطوم وفق معلوماتك ام لا شيء مؤكد ساعه
سفير
لا شيء مؤكد بسبب
بسبب ان المطارات حتى الان
لم يتم
التامين الشامل لها ولكن في بعض المطارات
مثلا مطار بورت سودان يمكن ان يمكن ان
تبدا قريبا يعني في استقبال
الطائرات بالذات الطائرات التي تريد من
الدول التي تريد ايجارها طيب عدد هذه
الدول اذا كان لديكم معلومات التي اعلنت
او افادتكم اختارتكم بانها ستقوم باجلاء
رعاياها هل من الممكن هل لديكم اي معلومات
عن عدد هذه الدول لسعه السفير
تقدمت معظم الدول ذات الدول الاوروبيه كل
الدول الاوروبيه والولايات المتحده وكذلك
الصين
وماليزيا اما بعض الدول العربيه
تحديدا السعوديه يعني انجزت مهمه الايجاب
منذ منذ منذ يوم تقريبا
عمليات الاجلاء ستتم بحرا جوا او برا عبر
الدول المجاوره ومن ثم جوا وفق المعلومات
هل تعطينا بعض التفاصيل ساعات السفير اذا
كان لديه
حتى الان ما تم بالنسبه بالنسبه للرعايه
السعوديين من البر الى
الى مطار ومنها للطيران
طيب دوركم في عمليه الاجلاء دوركم انتم
كخارجيه في تنظيم عمليات الاجلاء ما هو
دوركم
الخارجيه تتعامل بايجابيه في هذا المجال
وتتلقى كل الطلبات
وتعمل كل التسهيلات التي من شانها تمكين
الدول من اجلها راعيها والتنسيق مع الجهات
الامنيه لتوفير الممرات
الامنه وحراسه
وحراسه السيارات التي تقل البعثات
الدبلوماسيه
والرعايه والرعايه الرعايه الدول الاجنبيه
الى الى الى وجهتها خاصه مطار بورسودان
سعاد سفير مجرد ان تبدا الدول العربيه
الاقليميه والدوليه عمليات الاجلاء الا
يعني ذلك ان المواجهات تحولت الى حرب
مفتوحه ووصلت الى نقطه العوده
[موسيقى]
الحادث انه حركه التمرد بعد ان فقدت
السيطره على مقراتها وتعرضت لهدايا في
مناطق كثيره اتخذت
التعرض للبعثات الدبلوماسيه والمنظمات
الدوليه
لتشويه سمعه السودان ليس ذلك انا تعرضت
حتى للمواطنين
للمرافق العامه بالتخريب ونهب المواطنين
وترويعهم واتخاذهم دروعا بشريه
لتفادي لتفادي ضربات القوات المسلحه
السفير ابقى معي ساعود اليك بعد قليل فقط
لاذكر المشاهدين بهذا الخبر حيث تجري
الدول الاعضاء في مجلس الامن الدولي
مناقشات حول احتمال عقد جلسه مفتوحه بمجلس
الامن الدولي حول السودان يوم الاحد او
الاثنين المقبلين وقالت بعثه السودان في
الامم المتحده للعربيه ان الجلسه المقرره
سيتم عقدها وفق ق واعد الاجراءات الدوليه
ولا يمكن منع عقد الاجتماع طالما تم طلب
ذلك من اعضاء المجلس واضافت بعثه السودان
انه يجب ان تكون نتائج الاجتماع مرضيه
وليست مجرده ظهور اعلامي سعد سفير اي
تعليق على هذا الخبر وهل لديكم تاكيدات
بان الجلسه ستعقد اما الاحد او الاثنين ام
لا لا شيء مؤكد
لا شيء مؤكد حتى الان لكن
ما علمنا ان هنالك في بعض الدول يعني ترغب
في عقد الجلفه
طيب هل هل من يعني الا يمكن بشكل او باخر
وفق اي شروط يعني حمل الطرفين على الجلوس
الى طاوله المفاوضات
الان الان السودان يتعاطى ايجابيا مع كل
الطلبات الدوليه
واقرت اقرر الهدنه لمده ثلاثه ايام
لمعالجه
الحالات الحريه وكذلك
اجزاء الرعايه ومجلس الامن وهو يعني
وكثير من الدول الغربيه يعني
الان تهتم بموضوع
الهدنه لاداء الرعايه ومن ثم الدفع
بالحكومه السودانيه
والحركه والمتمردين
لايقافه لايقاف القتال
ومن ثم بدا بدا التفاوض بايجاد الحلول هل
هنالك اي مبادره بين الايدي يعني جرى
الحديث عن مبادرات طرحت من اطراف داخليه
سودانيه بينهم رئيس الوزراء السابق عبد
الله حمدوك هل من معلومات عن هذا الموضوع
هل يمكنك تاكيد ذلك ام لا لا شيء على
الطاوله ساعه سفير
لا شيء حتى الان
والسودان
يتعاطى بايجابيه في كثير من مجالات التي
يعني
يمكن يمكن يمكن التحدث عنها بعد اخماد
اخماد المحاور الانقلابيه
وخضاع واخضاع
قوات التبرجيل الى السلطه العسكريه من
الخرطوم السفير عبد الرحمن خليل الناطق
الرسمي باسم الخارجيه السودانيه شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
هذا واتهم نائب رئيس الاركان السوداني
الفريق عبد المحمود العجمي قوات الدعم
السريع بخرق الهدنه الانسانيه قبل ان تبدا
وشدد العجم على ان قواته تلاحق الدعم
السريع وتطردها من ولايات السودان
بغرض انسان فقط فيما تبقى من يوم يومين ان
شاء الله نعلن الخرطوم دي
ما في ولايه من ولايه السودان فيها حاجه
اسمها دعم شريف
المتبقيه هنا خلال اليوم يومين الموضوع ده
خلاص انتهى
هذا وقال شهود وعيان العربيه ان سته اشخاص
من عائله واحده قتلوا واصيب شخص اخر بجروح
خطره بعد سقوط قذائف مدفعيه على حي
المنصوره السكني في ام درمان
فكان من اولاد
المضروبين
في الميدان ضربت نكته ثانيه
قامت وطلبه هذه اللي كانوا
يعني
وانا
الى ذلك رصدت كاميرا العربيه ازمه الخبز
التي بدات في الظهور في الخرطوم حيث ظهرت
الطوابير امام الافران
لمزيد من المتابعه والتحليل ايضا ينضم الي
من الخرطومه الصحفي حافظ كبير استش حافظ
اهلا وسهلا بك لهذه التغطيه من العربيه
استمعت الى تصريحات الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان منذ قليل عبر قناه العربي اولا
ابرز ما لفتك في هذه التصريحات والمواقف
تحيه طيبه الكرام وكل عام وانتم بخير
يعني الذي يمكن ان نقراه من خلال تصريحاته
لاستهدات للتفاوض والحوار ووصفي للحرب
لانها عبثيه وهذا يعني التوصيف الصحيح
لهذه الحرب انها ليست حرب وكرامه كما كان
في البيان الاول وانها يعني
بالفعل ليس هناك فيها يعني
منتصر وانما الوطن سيخسر وبالتالي هذا هذا
اللي يجري الان ليس من
موقف اعتقد انه سيتقدم الى فعل ذلك خاصه
ان القياده الدعم السري بالامس بدايه
العيد اعلنت من طرفها من اتجاه واحد
الهدنه لثلاث ايام فهو عليه ان يحيي باحسن
منها يرد التحيه باحسن منها وان يعلن
الوقف اطلاق النار هذا يعني يعني امر جيد
اذا فعل ذلك اعتقد ان الظروف التي نعيشها
الان تقتضي او تحت تتطلب ذلك وان الحرب
العباسيه التي وصفها بالعابسيه هي
ليست من اجل المواطن وليست من اجل يعني
حمايته بل تسببت في مقتله والضرر به
والضرر بالبناء التحتيه وبالتالي
المخرج
الغائب في هذه التصريحات هو الخطوه
الفعليه خطوه العمليه ما الذي سيفعله تجاه
الحرب لان الانتصار للذات او الانتصار
المصالحه الذاتيه هذا امر لا يشبه
القيادات ولا يشبه الزعماء والانتصار يجب
ان يكون للمواطن وللمصلحه العليا الاستاذ
حافظ هل هل يستشف من كلام البرهان عبر
العربيه رغبه حقيقيه في التفاوض
ونحن من خلال
مختلفه لا نستطيع ان نؤكد الرغبات من خلال
تصريحات وانما ننتظر لانه
كانت لديها رغبه قويه في المضيق في اتفاق
الاطاري وكانت لديها يعني رغبه قويه في
حمايه المدنين امام تصام القياده وكانت
لديها رغبات كثيره لكنها لن تتنفس الان
يجب ترجمه هذه الرغبات في قرارات
وترجمتها في الواقع نحن ننتظر ونراقب هناك
شكوك بالطبع في كل الاتجاهات هناك عدم ثقه
في الكلام الذي يقال في الاخبار التي تصدر
هناك محاولات للتظليل محاولات لتغديش
الراي العام ومحاوله السيطره عليه او يعني
جره الى موقف معين هذا كله لن يفيد واقع
الامر يقول بان هناك حرب حتى الان مضى
منها اسبوع وتم تدخل في اسبوع الثاني وان
البلاد تعطلت فيها الحياه تماما وان هناك
خسائر كبيره جدا المطلوب الان
المطلوب الان المضي قدما في خطوات عمليه
وتحديد اليه الاليه التي تراقب خروج
الخروقات وتراقب وقف اطلاق النار كذلك
المطلوب ايضا في قدما نحو يعني مشاركه
الاخرين من القوى الفاعله السياسيه في
السودان في الذي يخص في القضيه التي تخص
البلد كلها وليس تفاوضا بين البرهان
وحماده
عندما في المقابل عندما يقول
الجنرال عبد الفتاح البرهان انه لن يخرج
من مقر القياده العامه الا على نعش الا
يعني ذلك ان الحرب باتت مفتوحه ومعركه كسر
عظم وان البلاد لا تتحمل جنراللين
سيد حافظ هل سمعت السؤال
لو سمحت ولكن كنت سالتك انه في المقابل
حتى في حديث قائد الجيش
الجنرال عبد الفتاح البرهان عبر العربيه
هو قال انه لن يخرج من مقر القياده الا
على نعش يعني من مقر القياده العامه حيث
هو متواجد الا على نعش الا يعني هذا
الكلام ان الحرب مفتوحه وان انها يعني حرب
كسر عظم والبلاد لا تتحمل جنرلين يعني اي
حلول وسط غير مطروحه
اذا كانت الحرب هذه حرب البرهان نفسه يعني
حرب شخصيه اعتقد ان هذا موقف ربما يعني
يخصه او موقف يعني يحمد له باعتباره يعني
قائدا لكنها لكنها البلاد تخص المواطنين
كلهم وبالتالي ينبغي عدم التمسك بموقف
واحد الموقف الواحد يتناقض
مع يت
ناقض حياه التي قالها بانه مستعد للحوار
يعني هذا اعتقد انه مفهوم في اطار الصراع
لكن في اطار البحث عن حلول لا ينبغي
التمسك بموقف واحد
البلاد ولا تتحمل جيشان ولا تتحمل وجود
جيش في السياسه البلاد تم تمضي نحو الامام
بان تكون السلطه المدنيه وانت يتولى
السياسيون العمل السياسي ويبتعد الجيش عن
هذه المهام ويتفرغ لمهامه التي من اجلها
يعني انشي اي جيش حمايه الدستور وحمايه
وتنفيذ القانون وكذلك حمايه الحدود
والدفاع عن سياده البلاد هذا هو المفهوم
البلاد مهما يعني تحدثنا من توافق شخصي او
هدنه او تفاوض ما لم توضع حلول جذريه
لمساله الجيش في السياسه وجوده في السياسه
سيتجدد النزاع مره اخرى ان لم يكن مع هذه
الحكومه وربما الحكومه قادمه او حتى بعد
الانتخابات وبالتالي لا بد من وضع الحد
لممارسه السياسه من قبل جنرال في الجيش
هذا الامر يعني تم التجاهله في الفتره
الاولى مشاركه المؤسسه العسكريه في السلطه
وكان دورها كما يقول البعض تعطيل الانتقال
كما حدث في خمسه اكتوبر وبالتالي عندما
تتمسك القوات المسلحه بالتفاوض والنقاش
والحوار عندما تدخل في تفاصيل السياسه
التي هي محل جدل ومحل الخلاف
تقدم ادواتها ادوات العنف كما يحدث الان
وبالتالي نحن يعني نريد ان عندما يفتح
مجال للتفاوض هو امر لا بد منهم ان يفتح
مجال تشترك فيه المجموعات السياسيه التي
تفاوض الان
تتحاور حول البلاد لا ان يكون هذا الحوار
بين بين الجنرلين لان هذه القضيه لا تخصهم
وحدهم
اي حديث الان عن تفاوض
وحلول هو حديث في محله ام لا يعني الوقت
خلاص سبق السيف العزل الان ال ال ال يعني
الصوت هو فقط للرصاص ويعني للميدان
ليس ذلك صحيحا في اي لحظه من اللحظات
الصراع هناك امل وهناك فرصه للتفاوض اذا
سقط مئه ينبغي ان لا يسقط العاده لا يسقط
101 شخص يبقى ايقاف الحرب هي بايقاف
الدمار هي بايقاف نزيف الدم يجب ايقاف
استنزاف البلاد هذه البلاد عندما تضعف هذا
ليس من المصلحه الوطنيه في شيء وعندما
تنهار ليس من مصلحه وطنيه ايضا في شيء
وعندما يموت شعبه هذا لا يحقق مصر لاي شخص
وعندما ينتصر احد على جماجم السوداني وهذا
ايضا لا يعتبر مصر وبالتالي الحوار
والتفاوض هو امر يعني هو
يعني انا لا اقول ينبغي ان يترك الجميع
خلافاتهم جانبا
يعني يتقابلوا بالوروث وفي اليوم الثاني
هذا امر مستبعد الان لكن ينبغي تغيير
الوسيله وسيله الحرب الى وسيله الحوار
والنقاش والتفاوض عبر اليات يتفق عليها
هذا ممكن خاصه بعد استمرار الحلق كل هذه
المده وعدم تحقيق اي نظر واي مكتب لاي طرف
نحن نراقب ونعرف ان جميع الان خاسر
المقدارات الكبيره الطرفين يعني مهمين جدا
للسودان الطرفين ابناء الشعب وابناء البلد
ينبغي استفاده منهم في الدفاع عن البلد
ولي ليس في حرب بينيه تضعف السودان لصالح
الاعداء الان ربما هذه الكلمات تسمع الان
الحديث الذي قالها مهم جدا لانه يخاطب
جنوده ويخاطب المتشددين في الطرف في الطرف
الذي يقف معه ويقول له ويشجعه باتجاه
الحرب
ويضغط عليه اكثر او كذلك يخاطب الطرف
الثاني بان هناك فرصه وان هناك امل وان
هناك الحل الوحيد ليس القضاء على الطرف
الثاني وانما هناك معادلات ليكسب الجميع
ويكسب الوطن من الخرطوم الصحفيه السودانيه
حافظ كبير شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
هذا وقال قائد قوات الدعم السريع الجنرال
محمد حمدان دقلو انه بحث هاتفيا مع وزيره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه التطورات في السودان
واضاف دقلو انه ابلغ وزيره خارجيه فرنسا
الالتزام بالهدنه ووقف اطلاق النار مشيرا
الى انه يتم العمل لتسهيل اجلاء جميع
الدول لرعاياها قائد قوات الدعم السريع
قال ايضا انما تم الاتفاق عليه سيكون له
تاثير مباشر على مجمل الاوضاع في البلاد
بالطبع الاخبار العاجله ترونها في عمليات
الاجلاء التي تقوم بها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه خمس سفن سعوديه بدات باجلاء نحو
158 شخصا من 11 دوله من السودان الى مدينه
جده اذا خمس سفن سعوديه تقوم بعمليات
اجلاء هؤلاء وهم حوالي 158 شخص من 11 دوله
الى مدينه جده السعوديه تحدث موقع
بحسب اربعه مصادر مطلعه عن كيفيه تفجر
الخلاف بين رئيس المجلس السياده قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو ومع ظهور خلافات
اهمال العالم اصبح من الصعب جدا اقناعهما
بالعوده الى المسار الديمقراطي فكلاهما
دخل في معركه سلطه لن تتوقف نارها الا
باعلان احد الطرفين النصر حسب
الاتفاق يمرق بلدنا يمرقنا لبر الامان ما
دايرين مشاكل ما كان
على الاطاحه بالرئيس المعزول عمر البشير
وبعد عامين طفت على السطح خلافاتهما وحولت
المشهد الى صراع سلطه
وبلادنا اصابها جرح بالغ موقع اكسوس
الامريكي وصف القتال بينهما بانه اشبه
بمعركه غرور كبلت السودان في هاويه
الصراعات الدمويه ومعها كشف كيف تفجرت
الاوضاع بينهما وحدد الشعره التي قسمت ظهر
الاتفاق الايطالي
اربعه مصادر مطلعه على المفاوضات اكدت ان
نزاعهما اخرج السودان عن المسار
الديمقراطي مرتين حيث تصاعد التوتر سريعا
مع بدء المحادثات ورفضهما الترحيب ببعضهما
او تبادل اي كلمات اعداء ترسخ عندما لم
يتمكن القائدان من ايجاد ارضيه مشتركه
بشان التسلسل القيادي العسكري لاعاده
تنصيب حكومه مدنيه ومن هنا كرت سبحه
الخلافات وانحرف السودان عن مسار انتقاله
الديمقراطي
فالبرهان يريد ان يكون الشخصيه العسكريه
العليا والوحيده التي تقدم تقاريرها
مباشره الى الحكومه المدنيه وكذلك احمدتي
يسعى الى ان تكون له قناه لا تمر عبر قائد
الجيش ولم يتفق على اليه تقاسم السلطه بين
الجنراللين والتي من شانها ان تمنح كلا
منهما حقا نقضي على القرارات
اما ارسال قوه الدعم السريع الى القاعده
الجويه والى الخرطوم كان فارقا واستفزازا
صريحا بالنسبه للجيش السوداني ومعه نسفت
امال ايجاد حل عبر الحوار خاصه وان حجم
الهوه بينهما يؤكد اللافقه من اصلها بين
الجانبين الذين جعل السودان رهينه
لخلافاتهما بحسب الصحيفه ما يجعل اقناع
الرجلين بوقف القتال بعيد المنال الا مع
اعلان احدهما النصر ببساطه وصل الى نقطه
لا عوده في تلك العلاقه اسراء الصغير
العربيه
الى الخرطوم مجددا لمزيد من المتابعه ينضم
الي من هناك الصحفي مقداد حسن مقداد اهلا
وسهلا بك بالطبع ازمه غذائيه حاده بدات
تضرب
السودان تحديدا الخرطوم
خصوصا موضوع الخبز هنالك يعني من يقول بان
ازمه الخبز مستفحله وانه لا يوجد طحين الى
اي مدى هذا الكلام صحيح لو تعطينا بعض
المعلومات كونك متواجد في احد الافران في
الخرطوم
اهلا ومرحبا
انا الاب مخبز بحي الجوز هي منطقه
الصوت يتقطع من مقداد لا ادري اذا كنا
تفضل مقداد انت على الهواء مباشره
يبدو مقداد للاسف لو
تكلمنا عبر الهاتف ممكن ان تعطينا صوره
اوضح لانه يعني هذا الاتصال عبر الهاتف
غير مؤمن الان او عبر الاقمار الصناعيه
على كل لمزيد من المتابعه ينضم الي من
القاهره محمد ابو الفضل وهو مدير تحرير في
جريده الاهرام ومختص في الشان الافريقي
استاذ محمد اهلا وسهلا بك الفريق عبد
الفتاح البرهان منذ بعض الوقت ادلى بمواقف
لقناه العربيه
مواقف يعني يجب التوقف عندها البعض راى
فيها انها تفتح مجالا
او رغبه في التفاوض والبعض الاخر لا راها
على العكس خصوصا عندما يقول انه لن يخرج
من مقر القياده العامه الا الا على نعش ما
الذي استوقفت في هذه التصريحات
وما الذي يستشف منها برايك
حقيقه هذه تصريحات في غايه الاهميه وتمثل
نقله نوعيه مهمه في خطاب المؤسسه العسكريه
السودانيه لانه يرد على كثير من المعلومات
والتكهنات التي دارت خلال الفتره الماضيه
ويؤكد على ان القائد الجيش على انه منفتح
على الجميع في مقدمه هذه المعلومات او
التي تضمنت هذه التصريحات انه ارسل رساله
بان مستقبل حميدتي لم ينتهي بعد يتوقف على
سلوكه خلال الفتره المقبله وهذا يعني او
ينفي قاعده
النظريه المعادله الصفريه التي مكاسبه
مكاسب البرهان هي خسائر لحميدتي او العكس
لكن هناك قابليه للتفاوض وهنا اتذكر ان
يعني حادثه شهيره جدا او تصريح للرئيس
الامريكي الاسبق جيمي كارتر عندما كان
يقود مفاوضات بين الحكومه السودانيه
والجبهه الشعبيه للتحرير السودان ايام
الراحل جون جراند
كثيرا بان السودانيون ان السودانيين
يقتتلون ويتهمون ويتبادلون الاتهامات ثم
عندما يجلسون على مائده تفاوضات ياخذون
بعضهم بالاحضان هذا هو حال السودان عموما
لمن يتابع السوداني فيما يتعلق بتصريحات
البرهان ايضا ارسل رساله في غايه الاهميه
عندما اكد انه لا توجد معلومات مؤكده فيما
يتعلق بدور او بعلاقه فاجنار بقوات الدعم
السريع وهي رساله غير مباشره الى روسيا
الحليف التقليدي للطرفين ايضا او التي
لديها علاقات قويه مع الطرفين وهي ايضا
تنفي علاقه تنفي علاقه حفتر
بتوصيل مع توصيل معدات عسكريه بين الطرفين
حول خاصه انك قد ترددت معلومات هذه
المساله لا اعلم مدى دقه ومدى صواب هذه
المساله لكن هي رساله سياسيه بالاساس قبل
ان تكون رساله عسكريه لمن يهمه الامر ايضا
هذه التصريحات تضمن اشاره مهمه جدا قد
تكون جاءت متاخره وهي فيما يتعلق بانه عدم
وجود علاقه بينه وبين فلول البشير الاتهام
الرئيسي في الخطاب قوات الدعم السريع انه
يعني انقلبوا او قاموا بحركتهم العسكريه
لتفويت الفرصه على الانقلاب عسكري مضاد
كان يقود فلول البشير والحركه الاسلاميه
ايضا هذه
المسائل كلها تصب في اطار ان هناك نوع من
انواع امتصاص الازمه في امتصاص الصدمه في
التعامل مع الازمه وهو يعني تطور مهم في
الخطاب استاذ محمد يعني حتى حتى لليوم
الثامن على التوالي لم تصمد اي هدنه يعني
جرى الحديث عن ثلاث او اربع هدن او هدنات
لم تصمت ولا دقيقه ولا واحده صمدت دقيقه
هنا السؤال هل الامور دخلت مرحله كسر عظم
حرب مفتوحه وان البلاد لا تحتمل جنرلين
اما كل
حاجه حل سياسي وجلوس على طاوله المفاوضات
هذا كلام يعني خلاص فاتوا الوقت
كل الاحتمالات مفتوحه في السودان لا احد
يستطيع ان يقطع بان الحرب يمكن ان تتوقف
غدا او بعد غد الان يعني مساله اجلاء
الرعايه والتصريحات القويه الخارجه من
المجتمع الدولي ومن قوه اقليميه متعدده
فيما يتعلق بوقف اطلاق النار وفيما يتعلق
بتوفير ممرات امنه وفيما يتعلق
الحيلوله دون وقوع كارثه انسانيه كبيره
كلها تؤكد ان هناك تدخلات كبيره لكن على
الارض هو الموقف الميداني هو الذي سيحسم
لاي اتجاه ستثير الامور لكن هي المساله
بتقدير انه لا يستطيع احد القول بانه يمكن
ان يحقق انتصارا كاسحا او انتصارا كاملا
عندما يتحدث قائد الجيش على انه تحقق
انتصاراته سيطره على مناطق عديده في
الخرطوم وحولها يرد ترد قوات الدعم السريع
بانها لا تزال لديها جيوب في الخرطوم
لديها جيوب ايضا في مطار الخرطوم وهذا
باعتراف البرهان هذه المساله يعني
تجرون الى معركه من البر والفر خلال
الايام المقبله طيب ابقى معي السيد محمد
سعود اليك بعد قليل استكمال هذه
الفكره انضم الي مجددا من الخرطوم الصحفي
مقداد حسن للحديث عن الاوضاع المعيشيه
تحديدا فقدان السلعه الغذائيه وشح في
المواد التموينيه تحديدا الطحين والخبز
مقداد اذا كنت تسمعني هل فعلا هنالك ازمه
خبز وطحين حاده ام هذه مبالغات
نعمل قبل قليل كنت على على بث مباشر
وحياتي لعدم توفر الصوره لم اتمكن من من
توفير هذه الماده انا الان داخل المقبل
بمنطقه الخرطوم غريب حي الجوز وهذا المخبز
صاحب المقبل يقول انه
استهلك جميع الكميات التي يهدها في
المواطنين وانه يعاني من مشاكل كبيره من
من نقص الالباب في في الخبز وكذلك الغاز
ووسائل الحركه لتامين وصول هذه المواد
التمويليه اليوميه كذلك كنت بدوله داخل
الاسواق
بالاحياء هنالك تخوف كبير وهنالك صعوبه في
الحركه من مكان الى مكان امداد المواطنين
بالسلاح الضروريه التي يحتاجها يحتاجها
يوميا يقولون انهم انهم اذا استمر هذا
الوضع بهذا الحال ربما يواجهون الموت
بهذه المنطقه وهنالك بعض المواطنين
يحاولون ان يتفائلوا ويتاملوا بالوضع
الراهن ويقولون انهم يتكاتفون الى حين
الازمه فهنالك
هنالك مواطنون يسكنون من من هذا الهلع ومن
هذه
الاستمرار هذه المواجهات وهنالك
تفاؤل في بعض الاحيان لكن عموما على
العموم
هنالك نص حار ضروريه التي تلامي حياه
الناس في هذه المنطقه هنالك صعوبه
بالمواطنين من الاسواق المركزيه التي تبعد
عن الديلومترات عده ويقول اصحاب هذه
البقالات وعلى الاسواق الصغيره انهم
يواجهون مخاطر كبيره جدا لتامين وصول هذه
السلعه الضروريه من الخضار والفواكه
اليوميه هل جميع الافران اي بس مقداد هل
جميع الافران تعاني نفس المعاناه ام لا
فقط الافران في الخرطوم في باقي المناطق
والولايات لا ماده الطحين مؤمنه ولا يوجد
اي طوابير حول الافران
الطحين مؤمن وموجود داخل المستودعات
المخابز بمنطقه الخرطوم بحري لكن
اصحاب
الوكلاء وكلاء الشركات التي تمد المواطنين
بهذه الاسئله الضروريه يقولون ان هنالك
اضطرابا امنيا لا يسمح بحركه هذه
منطقه ام جرمان
كنت على رقمي حسب
المواطنين هناك وبحسب الذين نعرفهم اكدوا
لان هنالك
صفوفهم من مدينه هنالك مخارج تعاني من
الغاز وهو كذلك يعني شيء ضروري لعمليه
الخبز وهنالك مخابز تنقصها عمليه الانجاب
فالحاله الامنيه الحاله الامنيه في في
الخرطومه ودورمان وبحري هو ما حال
دون وصول هذه المساعدات بحسب ما توقفنا
اليه من مطابخ مقداد هل بدات اسعار الخبز
ترتفع يعني بتعرف عند الازمات بعض التجار
او عندما يكون هنالك شحف ماده ما ترتفع
الاسعار وتكون هنالك اسواق موازيه او سوق
سوداء حتى في الخبز هل بدات بدانا نلحظ
هذا الشيء في الخرطوم
نعم
هذا المواطنون هذه النقطه الى ان ان حركه
التوصيل او تامين توصيل هذه السلع علمي
والى من والى المتاجر تواجه صعوبه كبيره
في في حيث ان حيث ان الشركات
يعني هنالك ارتفاع في اسعار فبالتالي
انعكس ذلك على اسعار الاسئله الضروريه
هنالك الى ارتفعت نسبه تقارب المئه في
المئه
طيب بالنسبه الى المياه طيب هي مؤمنه
وباقي السلع غير الخبز مثلا ام لا ما
ينسحب على الخبز ينسحب على باقي السلع
الاخرى مقداد
واضح جدا بحسب ما توصلنا اليه
ووصلنا للمعلومات وتاكيدات هنالك من جميع
السلع المواطنين من ارتفاع الاسعار ومن
صحها يواجهون يقولون يواجهون الان خطر
الموت اذا استمرا الحال على ما هو عليه
بالنسبه الى المياه نحن نشاهد هذه الصور
يعني يعني عاد الناس الى وسائل بدائيه جدا
جدا يعني حتى يعني بالايدي
وتعبئه بعض المستوعبات البلاستيكيه من
ابار محفوره في الارض نشاهد هذه المشاهد
هنا ايضا لو تعطيني اطلاله على موضوع
المياه وشح المياه مقداد
موضوع
ا للمحطات الرئيسيه التي تمد مدن العقل
الثلاثه
فالمشكله الامنيه هي انثى المشكلات
الحاليه كما يقول المواطنين كذلك نحن هنا
في منطقه الخرطوم غرب هنالك استقرار في في
في موضوع المياه بصوره يعني نسبيه
لا تعاني من مشاكل القطاع المياه لكن
هنالك احياء كثيره جدا في مواقع مختلفه من
الخرطوم حتى خارج العاصمه هنا عندي لدي
اتصالات العاصمه جنوبي العاصمه يقولون لهم
يعانون من انقطاع دائم منذ بدايه هذه
الاشتباكات المسلحه بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش غير هذه المشاكل من القطاع
المياه وبالتالي هنالك مشكله اخرى
وسائل التواصل مشكله في مصيده المكالمات
هنالك مشكله
في الوضع الحالي بما توصلنا اليه يعتز ان
هنالك مشاكل تواجه
طيب من الخرطوم الصحفي مقداد حسن شكرا زين
لك على هذه المشاركه عود الى ضيفي من
القاهره محمد ابو الفضل مدير تحرير في
جريده الاهرام مختص في الشان الافريقيه
استاذ محمد كنا نتحدث عن
سير المعارك ولماذا لم يتمكن الجيش حتى
الساعه من حسم حتى معركه يعني محيط المطار
مطار الخرطوم او حتى محيط مقر القياده
العامه لقواته
ما سر ذلك الى يعني الى هذا الحد المعركه
متكافئه مع العلم يعني انه نتحدث نحن عن
جيش نظامي يعني جيش منظم جيش سوداني
ما يحدد بشكل كبير مسرح العمليات ليلعب
دور مهم جدا في هذه المساله ربما يكون
الجيش السوداني متفوق في العتاد وفي
الطائرات وفي المعدات الحربيه المتنوعه
لكن الحرب تدور في المدن وفي الشوارع وفي
الافقه وبالتالي هنا يعني قيمه القيمه
النسبيه الكبيره والنوعيه للمعدات
العسكريه ستكون محدوده لتاثير عسكري كبير
في هذه الامور وبالتالي هنا يتفوق قوات
الدعم السريع في عمليات الكر والفر والتي
يجيدها اصلا من خلال خبرته الطويله في
معارك دارفورد
وهذه المساله تؤدي الى اطاله امد المعركه
ومن هنا ايضا من الصعوبه ان يحسم الجيش
العسكري هذه المعركه اذا اذا طالت واذا
اخذت هذا المنحه الكبير نحن شاهدنا على
مدار سبعه ايام الماضيه احاديث عن تفوق
هنا ثم تراجع هناك وما الى ذلك حتى
المناطق الرئيسيه التي يسيطر عليها الجيش
السود مثل المطار ومثل بعض المناطق
المفصليه
قد تكون فقدت قدرتها او خدمتها على
الفاعليه العسكريه ومن هنا ايضا يعني يرد
القوات الدعم السريعه لانها تتحكم في
مصالح في في مفاصل رئيسيه في شوارع
الرئيسيه وبالتالي تقطع الامدادات عن
الجيش السوداني هذه معركه عباسيه بالفعل
يعني من الصعوبه حسمها بالاله العسكريه
لكن ستستمر هذه الامور الى امد ان يستشعر
العالم ان هناك خطوره حقيقيه او تنفلت
الامور الامور من عقالها ونجد انفسنا امام
مسرح عمليات عسكري ممتده قد يفوق سوريا
وقد يفوق ليبيا وقد يفوق الصومال كما تعلم
ايضا ان السودان مليء بالاسلحه ومليء
بالمليشيات بالحركات المسلحه في في الشرق
وفي الجنوب وفي الغرب وهي ايضا مساله
تضاعف من صعوبه وقف اطلاق النار وبالتالي
هذا الكلام هذا الكلام ما تتفضل به يا
استاذ محمد يطرح سؤال استطراضي كيف تراقب
القاهره ما يجري خصوصا ان يعني هذا
التهديد كبير لامنها القومي
وهل ثمه اطراف تريد توريط مصر في فيما
يجري برايك
بالطبع انا يعني تقديري كمراقب للامور ان
هناك اطراف تريد توريد مصر سواء بشكل
مباشر او بشكل غير مباشر تريد الهاء مصر
الى او جرها الى مستنقع السودان وهو
مستنقع في غايته الخطوره لكن انا اعتقد
ايضا ان القاهره مدركه تماما لخطوره ما
يجري في السودان ولن تنجر الى معارك مهما
كانت الخطوره هناك لكن تتحرك ايضا على
مستوى
اقليمي وعلى مستوى دوري وعلى مستوى امني
وسياسي بشكل مباشر من خلال تواصلها مع
الاطراف المختلفه في السودان وهذا هو
الخطاب
خطاب وزاره الخارجيه حدد الكثير من الامور
في هذه المساله اما فيما يتعلق بمساله
اخراج مباشر لا اعتقد ان الامور يمكن ان
تصل الى هذا الحد لدى القاهره ادوات بحكم
خبرتها الكبيره في السودان وبحكم علاقاتها
المتشائبه مع قوه معتدله وقوى متنوعه ايضا
في مناطق مختلفه تستطيع بها ان تحافظ على
اموره لكن ان تصل الامور الى حد التسعيد
او الحد الانفلات هذا هو سيناريو خطير جدا
يمكن ان يهدد المصالح المصريه في السودان
بالطبع يعني من القاهره محمد ابو الفضل
مدير تحرير في جريده الاهرام ومختص في
الشام الافريقي شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه
هذا واكد وزير الصحه السودانيه هيثم محمد
ان القطاع الطبي يواجهوا تحديات في امداد
المستشفيات بالوقود مشيرا الى ان مخزن
الامدادات الطبيه الرئيسيه تدمر بشكل كامل
توجد صعوبه في ايصال الامداد الامدادات
المركزيه ما تاثرت كانت هنالك مشكله في
الوقود لها تم التنسيق مع
وزاره الطاقه على ستار لايصال الامداد
الوقود بالنسبه لهم وطمنوهم في هذا الجانب
للاسف المركز الامداد الرئيسي مخزن
امدادات الرئيس سي في ولايه جنوب دارفور
فيني نتعرض للاهلاك الكامل والحرق الكامل
من الخر
طوم من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع الدكتور
عطيه عبد الله عطيه وهو سكرتير نقابه
الاطباء في السودان دكتور عطيه اهلا وسهلا
بك اي تقييم للاوضاع الانسانيه
والاستشفائيه في هذا اليوم الثامن من
المواجهات والمعارك وهل لديكم اي ارقام
محدثه لما يعني نتابع عبر شاشه العربيه
الان
نعم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته في البلده خالق التعازي الجماهير
الشعب السوداني و الصحه والعافيه لكل
المرضى والجرحى وعودا حميدا لكل المفقودين
نعم الارقام تزداد كل دقيقه وايضا الاحوال
داخل هذه المستشفيات تزداد سوءا ايضا
يعني
توالي القصف وعدم توقفه وايضا يهدد
العمليات الانسانيه في هذه المستشفيات
وعموم الطرق المؤديه اليها لا توجد مسارات
امنه وهو الذي كنا نبحث عنه في منذ اليوم
الاول سمعنا ان هنالك عدد يعني مسارات
امنه وجدت لعدد مبعثات الدبلوماسيه ونحن
اصدرنا بيان بهذا الخصوص صبيحه هذا اليوم
هذه المسارات الامنه
عفوا لاجلاء الرعايه الاجانب وعدم فتحها
للمواطنين السودانيين هذا التعامل
بمكيالين يعني
وايضا هو ضد المواثيق والاعراف الدوليه
ايضا خروج هذه البعثات الدبلوماسيه
والبعثات الاجنبيه في السودان وهي التي
كانت تراقب من طرف محايد لطرفي الصراع
غياب هذه سوف يضع هذه الحرب او يتوجه بهذه
الحرب الى منحنى خطير
لذلك نحن نعم دكتور عطيه بالنسبه الى
المستشفيات دائما حديث انه 90% من
المستشفيات خارجه عن الخدمه بعض بيقول لك
95% هل في الكلام مبالغات ام لا يعني هذا
الوضع هو حقيقي تحديدا في العاصمه الخرطوم
هذا الوضع اكثر من حقيقي يعني قبل قليل
هنالك يعني وقع الدانه في مركز
لغسيل الكلى الحمد لله لم يصب احد باذى
تتوالى خروج المستشفيات نحن نتحدث عن فقط
23 او 22 مستشفى يعمل يعمل باقل
[موسيقى]
طاقه ممكنه يعني نحن نحن نتخوف ايضا من
خروج من بقيه بقيه المستشفيات هذه
المستشفيات التي تعمل كانت قبل هذه الحرب
اللعينه كانت مستشفيات كبيره وتقدم
خدماتها الكبيره الان في يعني بعض
المستشفيات تقوم باسعافات اوليه ونحن يعني
نعدها الان هي
جزء من
عفوا جزء من هذه التي تقدم الخدمه خروج
هذه المستشفيات وايضا توالي خروجها
وانقطاع الامداد الطبي ينبي عن كارثه
كبيره
جدا للنظام
الصحيحه واعلان اعلان
خروجه تماما من الخدمه في كل لحظه نحن
نتوقع في كل لحظه ان ينهار هذا النظام
الصحي تماما الذي يحدث ما لم يتوقف هذه
الحرب العباسيه فورا سوف ينهار النظام
الصحي تماما في يعني يمكن في النشر
القادمه ان لم يستجيب طرفين النزاع سوف
تزداد الامور سواء يتم اعلان ذلك في كل
لحظه نحن الان هل هنالك دكتور عطيه هل
هنالك اي صيدليات ما زالت الادويه متوافره
بها المستشفيات هل فيها ادويه ام يعني
لانه كذلك يعني عم نسمع كلام متناقض وبعضه
في مبالغات ارجو ان تعطينا فقط يعني حقيقه
ما يجري
الحقيقه كالاتي اغلب الصيدليات مغلقه
تماما للظروف الامنيه عدد من كبار السن
واصحاب الامراض المزمنه لا يستطيعون الى
الخروج وشراء ادويتهم لا توجد ممرات امنه
لكل المرضى حتى المرضى من كبار الصين
واصحاب الامراض المزمنه لا يستطيعون
الذهاب الى المستشفيات يعني
[تصفيق]
نحن هنا نتحدث عن ان المرضى ما قبل الحرب
اما
المرضى والجرحى بسبب هذه الحرب اللعينه
ايضا هم لا يستطيعوا الوصول لدينا عدد من
الجرحى الان يعالجوا على مستوى الاحيان
لعدم امكانيه ارسال اسعاف لديهم قبل قليل
اطفالهم يموتون لانه تعرضوا لرصاص طائش لا
يوجد اسعاف حتى نرسله اليهم لا توجد
مستشفيات لديها السعه الاستيعابيه لكل ما
يحدث عدد من المستشات قالت
كفايه لا نستطيع يعني استقبال عدد اضافي
للمرضى والجرحى وعلى نفس المنوال الحرب
تستعر لازال الطيران يحلق ولا زالت
الاصوات الرصاص في كل مكان ليس لدينا يعني
نحن الان نتحدث عن المستشفيات ميدانيه
نتحدث عن عن انشاء لخيم في في اي مكان حتى
نستطيع القيام بواجبنا الوصول الى هذه
المسلسلات اصبح من المستحيلات تماما انا
اقول ذلك بدون اي تخزين المشكله او بدون
اي تعظيم لها هذه الحقيقه المجرده
هذه حقيقه مجربه يجب ان نتعامل معها في
هذه في هذا الظرف اي كلام غير ذلك هو
محاول لتجميل الوضع تجميل الوضع سوف يكون
الخاسر الاوحد هو المرضى وجماهير الشعب
السوداني
اخر تحديث لعدد القتلى والجرحى عدد
الضحايا اذا كان لديكم كذلك عم نسمع كمان
ارقام مختلفه من من مصادر مختلفه انتم
كنقابه الاطباء في السودان اخر تحديث
لديكم يعني ونحن في اليوم الثامن من هذه
المعارك والمواجهه
نحن نتحدث حتى صبيحه هذا اليوم عن اكثر من
20060 شهيدا وسط المدنيين واكثر من 1460
جريحا وسط المدنيين فقط ومن داخل
المستشفيات التي وردتنا عدد من المستشفات
لم نستطع الوصول اليها حتى اللحظه ايضا لا
نحن لا نحصي الجرحى والقتل العسكريين
هذه الاعداد قابله للزياده لانه اذا فتحت
المسارات سوف نصل الى مستشفيات اكبر سوف
يتم ايجاد جزء من الشوارع والمستشفيات
وحينها فقط نستطيع ان نتحدث عن ارقام
محدثه لا زالت لا زالت جهودنا متواصله
بالقدر الممكن
في في توصيل المعلومه الصحيحه نحن نراجع
معلوماتنا مثنى وثلاثه ورباع حتى نتاكد من
صحتها تماما لذلك نحن نرجو من جماهير
الشعب السوداني الان البقاء في منازلهم
عدم تعريض حياتهم للخطر بالخروج الا بعد
التاكد تماما من الضمان سلامه الشوارع
ايضا نتمنى من الكوادر الطبيه التي تستطيع
بعد التاكد من سلامتها النزول الى اقرب
مستشفى لتقديم العون الاطلبي نعم ساكتفي
بهذا القدر من الخرطوم الدكتور عطيه عبد
الله عطيه سكرتير نقابه الاطباء في
السودان شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات